قامت قوات الاحتلال بتفجير منزل الشهيد
نصر الله القواسمي في مدينه الخليل جنوبيه
الضفه الغربيه وكانت قوات الاحتلال في وقت
سابق قد هدمت منزل الشهيد عبد القادر
القواسمي في الحي نفسه حي دائره السير عند
المدخل الشمالي لمدينه الخليل على ايه حال
ينضم الينا الان من الخليل مراسل الجزيره
منتصر نصار منتصر مرحبا اطلعنا على
التفاصيل ونحن نشاهد معك هذه الصور التي
ارسلتها الينا قبل قليل فقط والتي تظهر
لحظه تفجير منزل الشهيد نصر الله
القواسمي بالفعل محمد فجرت قوات الاحتلال
قبل قليل منزل الشهيد نصر الله
القواسمي بعد حوالي اربع الى خمس ساعات من
عمليات حفر وزراعه متفجرات داخل المنزل
يظهر ربما في هذه الصوره المنزل الذي تم
تفجيره قبل قليل قوات الاحتلال محمد لا
تزال تتواجد داخل هذا المنزل نشاهد بين
الفينه
والاخرى الاضاءه التي ت التي يستخدمها
جنود الاحتلال وهذا ربما يشير الى ان قوات
الاحتلال ستعود التفجير مره اخرى حيث ان
جرت العاده يعني كما يظهر في هذه الصوره
محمد هم لازالوا متواجدين داخل المنزل لم
ينسحبوا من المكان حتى بعد عمليه التفجير
في حوادث مشابهه ل هذه الصوره التي نوثقها
وننقلها تعود قوات الاحتلال وتفجر المنزل
من جديد بعد ساعه من تفجيره وهذا يشير على
الاقل الى وجود جنود الاحتلال حتى هذه
اللحظه داخل هذا المنزل حتى بعد التفجير
طبعا سبق تفجير منزل الشهيد نصر الله
القواسمي سبق ذلك هذه الليله هدم منزل
الشهيد عبد القادر القواسمي بالتزامن مع
القوه التي كانت تزرع المتفجرات في هذا
المنزل كان هناك قوه اخرى على مقربه من
هذا المنزل باليات هدم تقوم بهدم منزل
الشهيد عبد الله عبد القادر القواسمي الذي
سوته على الارض تماما
وفجرت منزل نصر الله قبل قليل هي لا تزال
تتواجد في حي دائره السير في مدينه الخليل
وكما ذكرت منزل الشهيدين يعني على مقربه
من بعضهما البعض لا زال قوات الاحتلال
تغلق كافه المداخل المؤديه الى هذا الحي
وتمنع المواطنين من التحرك وكانت
افرغت المنازل المجاوره ل منزل الشهيدين
سواء عبد القادر او نصر الله افرغت من
سكانها بالكامل واخلت هذه العمرات السكنيه
واعتلى جنود الاحتلال اسطح هذه العمرات
منذ حوالي خمس ساعات في هذا الاقتحام
المستمر قوات الاحتلال دفعت بتعزيزات
عسكريه استراليه كبيره الى المنطقه
الاقتحام كان كبيرا عدد الاليات التي
اقتحمت الخليل عدد كبير رافقها الياته هدم
نذكر المشاهد الكريم الى ان الشهيد عبد
القادر القواسمي والشهيد ناصر الله
القواسمي والشهيد حسن قفيشه هؤلاء الشهداء
الثلاثه نفذوا عمليه اطلاق نار في الس 16س
عشر من نوفمبر الماضي هذه العمليه عند
حاجز النفق جنوبي القدس ادت الى مقتل جندي
اسرائيل واصابه سبعه اخرين قوات الاحتلال
وفور وقوع العمليه داهمت منازلهم واعتقلت
ذويهم واجرت تحقيقات ميدانيه معهم واخطرت
منازلهم بالهدم واخذت قياساتها ومنذ حوالي
اسبوعين في الخليل قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت
هذه المنازل اكثر من مره في كل مره تلتق
الصور لهذه المنازل والمنازل المجاوره
واخذت قياساتها وبالفعل عمليه التفجير
والهدم تمت هذه الليله بقي منزل الشهيد
حسن قفيش هو منزل في عماره سكنيه مكونه من
ثمانيه طوابق المنزل في الطابق الثالث في
هذه العماره لم تداهمه قوات الاحتلال هذه
الليله رغم ان هذا المنزل مختر بالهدم
اضافه الى منزلين اخرين في الخليل في بلده
بني نعيم شرق الخليل تحديدا قوات الاحتلال
اخطرت منزلي الاسيرين احمد ومحمود زيدات
من بلده بن نعيم واللذان تتهمهما قوات
الاحتلال بتنفيذ عمليه رعنان التي وقعت
شمال تل ابيب قبل ايام اسفرت عن مقتل
اسرائيليه واصابه 18 اخرين كانت اقتحمت
هذه المنازل اخطرت ايضا وبلغت العائله
بنيتها الهدم لكن لم تهدم حتى هذه اللحظه
الهدم هذه الليله كان ل طبعا الشهيد نصر
الله القواسمه والشهيد عبد القادر
القواسمه اذكر مره اخرى لم ينسحب الاحتلال
من الخليل لازال متواجد في المنطقه يفرض
طوقا امنيا شاملا في محيط حي دائره السير
وبالتاكيد هذا يشير كما ذكرت ويدلل لربما
ان يكون هنالك على الاقل تفجير اخر لهذا
المنزل كما جرت العاده في حوادث مشابهه
وسابقه وبالتالي